North Korea's accusing the u.s. of
taking up a strike posture around the
Korean Peninsula for the first time in a
decade three American aircraft carriers
and their escort ships teamed up for
drills in the western Pacific the show
of force which ends today is widely seen
as a warning to Pyongyang Ben Tracy went
aboard one of the carrier's he's now in
the South Korean capital of Seoul Ben
good morning good morning the US Navy
says these exercises are about training
and preparedness but this was also a
massive display of military might right
in North Korea's backyard while
President Trump was in the region
the US Navy flew us out to the USS
Ronald Reagan to see it in person we
boarded a navy cargo plane at Osan Air
Force Base south of Seoul we were told
the flight would last about 90 minutes
when we reached the deck of the USS
Reagan
we saw f-18 fighter jets one after
another being launched over the waters
just off the Korean Peninsula if needed
these jets could strike military
installations in North Korea in just
minutes if there was a conflict they can
launch a fighter jet off his carrier
once
of course they then have to get holders
Jetts back on board this is how they do
but what the US military really wants
the world to see is this three US
aircraft carrier strike groups the
Reagan the Theodore Roosevelt and the
USS Nimitz sailing alongside each other
together they support about 200 aircraft
and their combined combat power
simulates what could be brought to bear
in a war with North Korea why do you
think these exercises are important we
can't be ready without that and to stop
those kinds of exercises we reduce our
ability to defend the United States and
our allies and maintain the peace and
stability in this region that is endured
for so many decades this naval exercise
has infuriated North Korea which is
calling it a deliberate military
provocation China and Russia have tried
to get the u.s. to freeze these military
exercises in exchange for North Korea
freezing its missile launches but
neither country seems interested in
doing that gale all right Ben Tracy
reporting from Seoul it's good to know
they're prepared and ready if necessary
once again reminder we have the greatest
military in the world Yeah right
they prepare and they're ready to fight
they don't have to fight yeah that thank
you very much Ben